[Music]
on today's show we talk all things
relationships we talked to a woman whose
dad cheated on mom and she's trying to
make peace with that relationship we
talked to a woman who's in love with a
hypochondriac and it's so hard and we
talked to a woman whose brother-in-law
is self-harming and doing drugs and she
doesn't know what to do stay tuned
[Music]
hey everybody this is john with the dr
john dolone's show and i hope you're
doing well hope your family's healthy
hope you're safe
hope you're laughing more than you are
not
i hope you got some joy in your life
on this show we talk about your
relationships and your relation on iq
how you talk to yourself and other
people we talk about your mental health
and parenting
everything anything you can think of
give us a shout if you want to be on the
show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 it's that's
1-844-693-3291
and um leave a message and then uh at
the beep because it's uh
when did answering machines come out
is it a while ago yeah i don't know
james is like i was born in this century
so i don't know very early 80s i
remember we got our first choice our
first answering machine oh yeah you were
in college then right
that was a good old person joke
i can make your life hell fyi you do you
absolutely already do probably exactly
uh leave a message and kelly may or may
not call you back just like when i was
dating in high school and
if you want to go to johndolone.com ask
you can do that too
hey last night i went and spent some
time
um after we got off the show i actually
went and spent some time
um at a local celebrate recovery group
here in nashville and just
spend a couple hours with them and i
tell you what man
what an amazing group of guys
i don't remember how many 20 30 men who
are trying to turn their lives around
who are struggling with addictions of
various kinds and who are committed to
being in community with one another
man
i left that group
so uplifted and
um
hard stuff and it was hard stuff and
they wanted to know how their brains
worked and relationships and some stuff
they could do and this and that so it
was a cool time where it's one of those
things where you i showed up to
be the
guy to answer questions and i walked
away with more of my questions answered
and more fulfilled man it was such a
gift but if you're struggling with
addiction find a local group and just
submit yourself to that group and to the
honesty and to the connection there it's
pretty incredible it's awesome
um all right james reminded me we have
this newsletter
we have thousands of people signed up
for it but there's bajillions because i
never talk about it so james what can a
person expect in this newsletter
it's mine that i write every week full
disclosure i i haven't actually
subscribed myself she'll probably do
that
but it's not like your typical
newsletter it's more personal and it's
very on brand for you there's a lot of
that
very on brand um if you listen to the
last show there's actually going to be a
new segment called animal uh geography
um where we teach you how and animals
run and escape from other animals
hey kelly by the way we just found out
james doesn't even subscribe to the
newsletter i don't even subscribe to the
newsletter so let's just be honest i'm
going to commit to doing it today go to
johndaloney.com that's d-e-l-o-n-y go to
johndalone.com scroll down and put your
email address in and subscribe to the
newsletter i'm doing it as we speak
you're literally not but it's cool i'll
do it right now as well because i don't
know you're not either sarah i get
enough of you good to see you would you
like to be the new producer and
associate producer of the john delonge
show
geez louise i bet sarah's subscribed i'm
not going to ask though because my
self-esteem can't handle it this morning
she's not either she said she didn't
even know we had one this is so cool
this is like the roadie of metallica
the guy running the board with
headphones in listening to fleetwood mac
or something like that hope you guys are
proud of yourselves
um
but i'm not subscribed either 100 chance
my wife's not guaranteed my family's not
but hey we're today we're turning that
around there's literally thousands of
people subscribed to this thing and
i write it it's
listen i hate uh
i hate them i hate email lists i just
unsubscribe there's like three people in
the world that i get their email every
week and i look forward to it and so i'm
trying to make mine one of those so
please john delaney.com scroll down
subscribe to the email list and as james
says it's on brand it's about as
teetering on one of the of the train
rails
without falling over but it's a blast
man it's cool stuff that i've read
stumbled upon pro uh like gadgets that i
like
um
things that i bringing me joy out in the
world all that stuff so subscribe to it
and um we will connect that way as well
or if you don't want to you can just be
like james and kelly
just uh
getting all this i don't know
never mind y'all are both beautiful and
kind and brilliant all the things all
right let's go to
uh laurel in fort wayne indiana before
this thing gets further off the rails
what's up laurel
hi thanks for taking my call dr john no
thank you hey you've been on you've been
on the phone for a while and so you got
to hear all the behind the scenes stuff
just for the average listener
we don't just turn this on for the
camera right
you guys are doing a great job
oh i'm saying nicer though is connors
back on the the youtube videos thank god
cause zach what is that guy doing anyway
connor you kicked him out way to go man
good job all right laurel what's going
on how can i help
okay so basically my question is how can
i move on from
a past hurt and it's about 15 years
going now
without getting the closure that i think
that i need
so basically um my mom and dad divorced
about 15 years ago how old were you my
mom discovered um i was about 25 okay at
the time
um i have
three other siblings or all adults at
the time
my mom discovered that my dad was having
an affair
and
it was just completely shocking and
destroyed our family
um we all kind of went our separate ways
and we don't talk we don't see each
other anymore
um you and your dad however um
he
we i didn't talk to him for a couple
years but i've tried to um
amend the relationship and honor my dad
and be respectful and
just try to show up and um it's still
kind of rocky it's never been the same
so
basically my dad
he quickly moved on
married the woman he was having an
affair with and she had two daughters
one of which was still living at home
and
she never found out about how our
parents got together
and um i guess fast forward 15 years and
i've been going through to holidays and
family gatherings and um i've just kind
of suffered in silence without being
able to move on and heal and
um can i ask you a hard question
yeah sure
um
why why have you chosen that path
that seems like an exhausting
path you've put yourself
on
15 years it's a long time to carry that
how come you've chosen to carry that
i guess
i guess i expected
i expected um
everybody to find out and and then we
can all
move on together um
i also
i don't know i just i have a hard time
bringing it up with my dad
um
i don't know he's the kind of guy who
wants to move on and everyone should get
over it this is
this is um happening with or without you
so
he's just he's kind of hard to talk to
also so why do you want to maintain a
relationship with him he sounds pretty
dismissive of his family of you guys of
your past of your mom
um
i
um i have a son and he loves his grandpa
um and
i don't i don't know i i am to the point
where i i just want to
and i just want to stop
seeing them all together um
it's just yeah it's just hard
um but i also want to
you know honor my father and do the
right thing and
one of the things the great thing for my
son yeah
that's a hard place and i want to honor
hey your trust here and be
um
it's one of those things that you hear
about but it's different what happens in
your house and
then it's easy just to
freeze and then think i'll deal with it
tomorrow and then suddenly tomorrow's 15
years later
and there's some imaginary i'd say
fantasy is kind of a dismissive word but
there's a fantasy that this stuff will
just play itself out or the dad will one
day call and be like what did i do and
i'm so sorry
and then that turns into one year and
then two years and three years and you
kind of find yourself waiting for that
call or that he takes you out for coffee
and says hey i really screwed this up
and i'm so sorry i hurt you and those
things never come and suddenly you look
up like you said you've got your own
kids now and my guess is you are
probably waiting for um
somebody to cheat on you and your
relationship like you can't ever breathe
the other side of that is
there is a difference between respecting
the
um i wish i had another word for it
respecting the office respecting the
position
and being honest about the person who's
in that seat
and you can respect your dad
and
not to speak to him on a regular basis
you can respect your father meaning i'm
not going to talk bad about it i'm going
to treat him with dignity um and i don't
want him around my kids because he's not
hasn't been a person of integrity he's
not safe
he's not a person willing to own up to
mistakes that he threw a grenade in the
middle of my family and then he just
walked away and acted like it was no big
deal
and some of that is you
probably have had a thousand if not ten
thousand imaginary conversations where
you just let him have it and you tell
him and he cries and says i'm so sorry
is that right
yeah yeah
and my question for you would be
like
what is that conversation gonna solve
for you
i i've thought about that and i don't
i don't think anything
yeah
i i think about like my step-sisters
actually knowing and what that would do
to them and it's like that does not help
me yeah i'll say if they find that out
about their mom that doesn't help me you
finding another group
yeah and throwing it back at him
right you know it doesn't
it won't if it feels like it will feel
good i'm telling you it won't because
then you what you're going to do is be
opting in to put two more young daughter
young women
um and the same put them through the
same hurt you did as an attempt to stab
your dad and that won't feel good for
anybody
all that to say is
answer this for me
what are you looking for
where do you find peace in this
situation
i don't know i guess i
i don't i just
i don't know it seems like he's moved on
and is happy and it's it's almost like
he's chosen a new family and
that's always been in the back of my
head and
i just never wanted to accept that yeah
i did
yeah
dads aren't supposed to choose other
families
and with all of my guts i'm sorry that
he did that to you
i'm sorry i did that to your brothers
and sisters and did that to your mom
thank you
but you
and your little one are paying the price
for living in a mythological land
and not dealing with the reality is that
your dad moved on
and
the sooner you can
make peace not not make it okay
but you can own
this is what happened to me and to my
mom the woman i love and to my brothers
and sisters
then you can make rational real true
honest integris decisions about what
comes next
and that may include your son going to
play with him that may include you
telling your dad hey i'm not really
comfortable with you around my son like
man i just don't want him picking up on
how to be a
grown man out of love i don't want to
pick that up from you so we're just
going to move on
or it might be yeah son you can go play
and that's cool and when dad says hey
everybody i want to do this you can say
no you you opted into a new family so um
you have a good time and we're gonna do
thanksgiving this way
and that'll hurt but that will be more
honest your body will stop trying to
fight different things
yeah
yeah that's what i've been leaning to is
just saying okay i have
i have my new family or i have my family
and we're gonna just we're gonna just do
our own thing on the holidays and
and
you can do your own thing how does that
sound when you say it out
loud um i like that
that's my guess
it's peaceful
because right now you're playing house
or you're playing trying to make
everyone happy yeah my five-year-old
always says hey can we play family
and i always think we are one but i know
what she's talking about she wants to
right she wants to be mom and wants me
to be like a cat or something
um but
it feels like you're playing family and
you're the person trying to hold
together
a
fantasy and
instead of playing family i'd love for
you to
create co-create are you married
yes yeah i'd love for you to co-create
one with your spouse and man y'all just
go be about it
okay it's not going to make it just
instantly like ah good
but what i'm telling you is if you will
do
the work of grieving it
letting it go
and then living in the reality
of how my dad was a scumbag man he
bailed on us
he's not even being honest with his new
stepdaugh step kids
yeah and that's the guy he's chosen to
be i don't know if i want my son around
that or i don't care if my son's around
that he's getting good stuff for me and
his
his dad
um
and then just making peace with it
yeah do you think that's possible
yeah i think i need to just
step out of those like
you know family quote-unquote
get-togethers um because that's where it
just reminds me of it and
yeah i need to
i need to say no
well and do it affirmatively plan
plan something instead
sometimes we take things away and we
just end up empty we don't end up
fulfilled so
um plan an awesome friends giving that's
going to be a blowout this year that
you're going to
invite people over to your house you're
gonna do a whole thing
and it's gonna be a
table full of misfits and it's gonna be
the one that you and your spouse are
gonna plan together and you get to you
get to pick it
it's gonna be a blast and design what
you love
and then you set your boundaries around
that
and man
and one more quick thing
um
sometimes we feel in these situations
i it hasn't happened to me so i won't
say we i won't co-opt it but sometimes
when
parents
cheat on each other and the kids are
involved
the kids feel like if i don't hit back
i'm betraying my other parent
especially as adults if i go actually go
to his house he did he abandoned my mom
that sucked 15 years ago but he's
actually a fine guy he's all right
and i like him and i would like to have
a relationship with him i'm gonna do it
on my terms with my boundaries but i'd
like to have a relationship with him but
i feel like if i do that i'm betraying
my mom
that can be equally abusive on the other
end
you're an adult and you get to decide
who you're in relationship with you're
an adult you get to decide
who you want to open doors to who you
don't want to open doors to
you're an adult and you get to decide
who's around your family who's not who's
around you what your holidays look like
etc
and so this goes on both sides of this
deal
you do need to respect your mom do you
respect your dad i believe in that big
time but you have to have firm
boundaries especially when they are
people who betray you and they're not
safe
and so if you want to reach out to him
and
have a relationship with him however
wonky it might be
feel free to do that
the key here is to make sure everybody's
on the same page that you are honest
with everybody you don't do stuff behind
people's back you don't hold secrets if
you're not gonna be around thanksgiving
or christmas with your dad this year let
him know
i'm not coming this year you all have a
great time i'm doing friendsgiving with
my neighborhood
hey mom i'm reaching out to dad and i'm
going to spend some time with him at
christmas this year
it's time for me as an adult to forgive
him for the past and try to reconcile
some sort of relationship with him even
though he fill in the plane
put everybody up in the forefront be
honest with everybody and if they want
to act and mature that's their job
that's not yours to solve
you've done a lot of solving for a lot
of adults and it's time for you laurel
[Music]
to co-create your adult world with your
new family
you deserve it and you're worth being
well we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the doctor john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to elaine
in pittsburgh hey what's up elaine
hey dr john how are you remarkable how
are you
good i am now a subscriber to your
newsletter yes
guess who's not james and kelly
i am now i beat him
oh you are now james i told you i
literally did it when we were talking
about it have you already hit
unsubscribe
it's probably getting filtered through
spam it is dude hey you just made my day
elaine i am not subscribed but i'm going
to be by the end of today so you beat me
to my own newsletter we're going to make
it really big things
all right so let's take your
expectations and dial them back about 40
percent but we're going to get that okay
we're going to get there um thank you so
much hey so what's up how can i help
well i'm calling today because i
have a husband who i feel is a bit of a
hypochondriac
so i was just looking for some insight
into how i can better meet his needs
because i feel that every reaction i
have to him ends in a very negative way
so why do you think he's a hypochondriac
what does that mean to you
so he well i didn't notice anything
while we were dating or engaged probably
infatuated with him still you know and
then after how long have you been
married
seven years
oh yeah all right see
so after some you know i noticed while
we were married i'm like oh he complains
of headaches a lot you know a couple
days a week he's complaining of
headaches
and then i would say within the past six
months to a year it's really gotten to
the point where he was convinced he had
lyme's disease he's going to his pcp
requesting blood work
he um
he's been to a cardiologist within the
past year complaining of chest pain he's
like racking up medical bills at this
point and he went to a podiatrist for
foot pain he went to a uh
and his ear hurt so he was going to an
ear nose and throat doctor
and then it just sort of got to the
point where about a week or two ago he
we're like laying in bed and he looks at
me and he is i i think i have a brain
tumor and i just
was like what what hulk you know what
so i said to him look me in the eye and
tell me that you you honestly think that
you have a brain tumor so he did and he
was very serious and then of course it
escalated into
you don't believe me and how can you not
love me i'm dying and you don't even
care exactly yes
you nailed it yes and i it's not true
you know i love him so much and i just
want to give him what he needs and i
just cannot figure out
what exactly he
wants i feel like at this point he
almost wants to be sick and yeah looking
for something
and i just don't understand what he's
looking for and i just i just really
want to help him i'm not sure how oh man
so this is beyond so um when you first
said he's a hypochondriac i
i thought it was a this is you know uh
generalization but
um
my wife reminds me often that she had
children and so
i she knows i have a headache but i need
to get up and fill in the blank right or
exactly how i feel on one hand i feel i
want to help him i want to meet whatever
needs he has i can't figure out what
that is but on the other hand i'm like
chop chop buddy we got you guys
you know
i got a brain tumor well great into the
dishwasher we'll talk about it later
excellent right exactly so has there
been any sort of finding at all
from any of these doctor visits
no and then i've noticed that when after
he goes he kind of leaves off of it he's
kind of good to go but then they just
keep building up on top of each other
it's like it gets even more
almost fantastical like now we're at the
point where he has a brain tumor i'm
like oh gosh
number one nobody's ever used the word
fantastical on this show ever so elaine
you get a special star i may call you
out in the next newsletter for excellent
word to use fantastical i'm writing that
down all right so
this actually sounds so hypochondriac is
like one of those words like narcissist
um or i've got anxiety or i've got adhd
it's just it's a diagnostic that's
thrown around a lot
this actually sounds like what you're
dealing with not just somebody who's got
a low pain tolerance or somebody who
actually has some medical issues that
they're trying to figure out
this sounds like somebody who has made
um
medical fears a part of their identity
so being having a medical diagnostic a
diagnosis is becomes part of a
hypochondriac's um identity like you and
you nailed it he almost it feels like he
wants to be sick he doesn't want to be
sick but like he doesn't want to hurt
and be dying
but there this has become part of his
identity that i go to doctors i google
things and i've got phantom pains and et
cetera
so
um hype contract another way to think of
it is a an illness
anxiety disorder is really what it is
and
it does sound like he needs some
psychological care right now
and not in over dramatic way but i do
think he needs to go talk to a counselor
about where this
where this is coming from because here's
the loop you get in you go to a doctor
they do all the tests and they say i
don't know here's some take some vitamin
d i mean they'll make up something
they'll give you something or try this
thing for 12 days and see if it feels
better
and
this is my opinion i don't have any data
to back this up
but i know that anxiety i do have data
to back up anxiety is a connection issue
it is people who are disconnected
i have a strong hypothesis that those
who struggle from hypochondria they get
that connection through doctors through
experts
somebody that will look at them give
them 30 minutes of undivided attention
give them their expertise their opinions
and their bodies go
i'm connected
and then they get home and
they spin up something else and then now
i've got to go find the next so you went
from headaches to
foot pain to any sorts of anything has
there been a lot of covet related stuff
no actually
no no
okay so and then now we're at brain
tumor and cancer is usually the big one
right i've got cancer this is happening
it's all coming down and let's be honest
there is a minuscule statistical problem
i mean possibility
that he's got brain cancer probably not
we all walk around with that
every day right
so
most hypochondriacs the the word i've
i've heard use that i love is they need
a witness
and when we love somebody who is
struggling with this type of challenge
it becomes more as you say fantastical
and it's hard to be a witness to
like hey look i'm writing a unicorn
check it out it's like okay great i need
you to go outside and finish the yard or
whatever
and we also have to realize that the
mind is so powerful
so incredible the research on placebo is
staggering
and it can create
real pain and real challenges it can it
can manufacture them on its own if you
will
so what i'm telling you this is this is
actually hard this is harder than it
sounds and i do think he needs to go
talk to somebody
and i do think it's probably rooted in
anxiety and again i'm not talking to him
and i do think there's some pc finds
through the connection through medical
providers and it does get really
expensive and it does get really
really hard to be in relationship with
somebody similar to somebody struggling
with anxiety
what are things you all have tried in
your home
well
i've tried everything from
sympathy to tough love and it all seems
to end the same way as it like exactly
like you said like you don't love me
you know you don't care and then it ends
up with me saying no i do love you
that's right and i'm also a nurse
[Laughter]
no you're not going to bring your
knowledge to this situation are you
right so he'll ask for my opinion and
then he
and
you're right we have
half bottles of pills laying around and
you know the foot doctor said take these
pills for a month and that was over the
summer and there's still a half bottle
of pills of course
right right so i just and i if i tell
him straight out like if i take the
tough love approach and say
it it's just
a total nightmare but i also don't want
to get if you give in to the
the uh
like oh well maybe maybe you should go
get it checked out
that causes almost like a spiral as well
like he just keeps going with it and
until we end up at a doctor and and you
know i do
sense that it is much more anxiety
related
and um
if i bring that up to him i have brought
that up to him it's uh
no
you don't believe me exactly yeah and
it's really hard to be in relationship
there because then it's a spiral at that
point you can't win that engagement
there's you're in a place where you
can't fix this
what you can do is love him
you can
um the next time you'll go to some
doctor to go with him
and let them know i believe at this
point here is the
here's our trajectory and you hand that
doctor here's the last set of so let me
back up
here's um and i've talked about this i
think on this show i know i've talked
about it in some live events recently
um
really cool i read a book by ethan cross
and i mean i read several books a week
and occasionally one or two things will
stick with me
or i'll add to a body knowledge this is
one that was extraordinary for me i'd
never heard it i thought it was mumbo
jumbo and i've tried it and it is
unbelievable how successful it's been
so i run pretty hot when it comes to
anxiety and i can i can
i have i have a pretty regimented life
it's a silly fun life but i have a
regimented life so that i don't get to
those places and over the last decade i
mean i'm almost
anxiety free but if i get tired and i
don't eat right and end and then i start
withdrawing and i can find myself spun
up if i let it get that way
so
ethan cross the book's called chatter
and it's about the inner voice and
there's been evidently been a lot of
research on the inner voice in our heads
that just keep going all day every day
all day every day just telling stories
stories stories stories stories
and he
dropped some information that i'd never
heard before and here's what here's what
he said
he said
when our bodies
think and solve for i or we
there is a neural circuit that
the i and we conversation inside our
head operates on and it's the
fight-or-flight circuit
so
i don't know what i need to do i don't
know if i should be buying this thing
should i even be moving to this house
should i marry this person should we
have another kid
that is an immediate threat that your
body tries to solve and it solves it and
you know this as a nurse it solves it
with adrenaline and cortisol and
dopamine all kinds of things with um all
sorts of hormones and neurotransmitters
all this stuff
when we think of them
they
our bodies don't take off on us
it doesn't try to solve that it's a
different circuit
and
and i hate using tech
metaphors to describe the human brain
but it it's easy on this one
so
what this guy's recommendation was when
you have hard decisions to make if
you're struggling with addiction if you
are working through really tough
challenges
talk to yourself in the third person
write your journal in the morning in the
third person
because here's what happens
when i'm struggling i teach
relationships in marriage and parenting
for a living and there are times i don't
know what to do with my kids and i'm
just scrolling like in my mind what am i
supposed to do here
then my buddy calls and says hey my son
is filling the blank is doing this this
and this and i can go well yeah just do
that that and that
because my brain's not in fight or
flight my prefrontal cortex is still
connected
and so
if i talk to myself in the third person
often
my brain doesn't react my thinking brain
my rational brain stays intact so what
does this have to do with your situation
number one i want you to keep a front
and present spreadsheet
or a word document that has all of the
ailments and the dates and what y'all
did
okay and i want this to be an ongoing
list that can be seen
because anxiety thrives off chaos
and so we're going to clear this up
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to talk to let's say your
husband's name is tom we're going to
talk to tom and the third person
because my guess is if your husband had
a buddy show up
and say hey man i thought i had foot
pain and then i thought i had chest pain
and then i thought i had headache pain
and then i thought of neck issues pretty
sure it's a brain tumor your husband
would probably say i bet you don't just
as a first default response
but when it's your body
your body takes over for you and then
it's in fight or flight and then we're
not thinking straight
and so
when he comes to you with a new ailment
i want you all to write it down and
maybe maybe even put i'm going to be
obnoxious here okay but maybe put a star
wars figure or a lego figure or some
sort of something on the coffee table
and i want you to talk to tom
and say tell tom what your what your um
what your symptoms are what are you
feeling and what would we tell tom that
he should probably do
and your husband should
be able to have that conversation
without it becoming internalized and the
hope there is you begin to have
more
i don't say rational but more
um fact based
more direct more um yeah more rational
conversations about do i really have a
brain tumor what is the data that would
tell me i have a brain tumor
and begin to go down that road that
makes sense
and then when you go to the doctor next
time i want you to take this list and
hand it to the doctor
and let the doctor know i am concerned
as a medical professional that this may
be an anxiety disorder than
more so than physiological
challenge
and your husband may get upset with you
he may say you don't trust me you don't
believe me
and call that out in front of the doctor
i'm struggling with connecting here and
it may be on me um but we've here's all
the things we've been through and that
sort of clarity for a doctor would be a
gift
and
know this
you can't solve this anxiety disorder
with your husband you can't solve it and
it's going to be fu
rustic straighting
frustrating not a word that's
fantastical it's going to be frustrating
um
what you can do is love him
not give in to either side of this thing
not given to the despair and hitting
outside the head and also
we're gonna put some boundaries on how
many times we go to the doctor
unless we have some real evidence that
suggests you may have some some maladies
and some challenges but i want us to
talk to tom not to your husband but i
want us to talk to an external third tom
and begin to look at the data it was
feet and then we had about a week of
whatever this medication is and it all
went away
we had headaches and we weren't able to
solve them we had backaches we weren't
able to solve them now our knees hurt
and there's no solving there and now
we're under brain tumors
and hopefully if we're talking to tom we
can keep our brain plugged in
it won't go limbic on us we'll be able
to look at the data and
then at that point we can say
okay maybe it's something a little bit
different
and i hate that for you
the last step you can do is you go see
somebody
and you model counseling you model
living with somebody who's got lots of
medical challenges you can tell your
husband this i don't know how i can help
you because you seem to be moving from
medical challenge to medical challenge
to medical challenge and i want to love
you and i don't know how because every
time we go get the medical challenge
taken care of
there's no findings
and i'm struggling with how to love you
in this situation the hope being that he
joins you the hope being that you
continue to invite him you continue to
say i want to love you i want to connect
better and i don't know how to do that
one final final thing
hold his hands every single day and look
him in the eye and tell him that you
love him
and i want you to begin practicing
skin-to-skin contact it can be sexual it
can be non-sexual
begin to lean into let's don't talk i
just want to hold you i just want to
touch your your hands you want to touch
your face when i touch your feet i want
to hold you
and
the anxiety alarms begin to
whoo this one's tough elaine tough tough
tough
if you're struggling with anxiety go see
somebody you're worth it we'll be right
back on the doctor john the woman show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back don't forget
johndaloney.com scroll to the bottom and
sign up for the newsletter
is that a good pitch i'm so terrible at
this
buy my new used car out i don't know how
to do this listen the newsletter is
going to be rad it is rad and it's going
to be rad or with you in the game all
right let's go to sarah in
minneapolis minnesota did i say that
right did i get it no
[Laughter]
how do you say it
minneapolis
did i say minneapolis
you're dead oh dang gina okay
minneapolis
there you go i'm gonna go with minnesota
is that cool that works too that works
minneapolis
minnie nap minneapolis minute what's up
sarah how can i help
hi john i'm calling today my
brother-in-law turned 15 and
over the last few months we've noticed
some disturbing behaviors
smoking weed cutting um and now the
latest has been um
drinking and getting drunk around family
members
um we just feel like you know my my
in-laws aren't necessarily
doing enough and and we're afraid of of
what comes next and so we're looking to
see how how do me and my husband
speak to my in-laws about this
have you all spoke to them yet
we've tried but it never
it never goes well
it always gets shut down and we're told
you know we're not the parents you don't
know
um and stuff like that
um
this one's hard
um
and it's hard for a couple of reasons
one is they're right you're not their
parent this kid's parent and
right the the scent the sentiment of
mind your business were the parents fair
enough
where it gets hard in my book is is a
child
it's a kid and i believe that
neighborhoods raise kids
and i believe if i see a kid in an
abusive situation
and or if a kid is not safe as a
community member i'm going to step in
and get involved in that um kelly sent
me an awesome thing yesterday
um
about a dad who was was taking his kid
that he like tj maxx cole something like
that yeah kid was having a tantrum yeah
kid was having a tantrum a dad was
carrying his daughter over her shoulder
and kid was screaming and hollering
turns out she wanted to buy a toy or
something
and dad said no we're leaving
and
a guy was walking into the store in the
parking lot and
so imagine a guy's walking out of a
store holding a kid over his shoulder
and the kids screaming and yelling
saying
and this man in the parking lot stopped
that dad
and said hey what's the problem kid are
you okay and the kid said no i'm not
okay daddy won't whatever let me buy it
it was a luffa sponge a loofah sponge
right
but
the dad who of the child ended up taking
out a picture saying i'm the dad here my
kid's throwing a temper tantrum
and then he went on to say and thank you
for stopping me
because if someone had been taking my
daughter out of the store i'm so glad
that people like you exist and are
willing to get in the middle of
something that doesn't look right even
if it's just a check-in
so i tell you that to say i believe in
that and if i see a kid screaming in a
store and it looks like there's a not
safe situation i'd rather ask than not
you're in a messy situation right now
because this is your in-laws and this is
gonna
wreak havoc and what i would tell you is
havoc's already been reeked is that fair
that's fair yeah so i would
make one final have one final
conversation that goes along the lines
of
we've got a kid who's self-harming
who has taken drugs who's now
intoxicated he's 15.
he's underage on all counts he's not
getting the mental health care that he
needs he's not clearly not getting the
boundaries and parental connection that
he's desperate for
all of those behaviors are him screaming
will somebody see me
and
they're not
and so i would let them know directly
we're going to call the school
we're going to call the local child
protective services and get somebody
involved in this young man's life
before we are all at a funeral or we are
all pooling money to bail him out of
jail
and that will be a disaster of a
conversation that's your husband's to
have not you i just made an assumption
you're married right
yes we are yep we are it's his to step
up and say that's my brother
and i'm not going to allow my brother to
live in this situation
and it's going to be that level of
directness and i wish there was another
thing i could tell you
but that's the next step
and that's the step i would take in my
world
that little boy that 15 year old little
boy
which i know it's 15 year olds can be
gigantic and they have hairy legs and
they smell and they make out with girls
and they whatever
he's a kid he's a child
and he needs some adult in his life to
step in and say i love you too much to
not keep you safe right and we know he
has a therapist that he sees but
it's not it's things are getting worse
and
and it's just it's hard to watch is he
have a relationship with your husband
um yes he does my husband is um about 11
years older so it's
not as brotherly as it is with um
other siblings sure um so what is more
of a do they connect though does he tell
him the truth does he tell him what's
going on
he does
he does but it's probably not as often
not as often as it should be
you all live in the same community
yes we do we live very close okay
it may also be worth a conversation with
and and i'm using these words
intentionally your husband bringing his
little brother over the house to meet
with y'all too
you say hey what's going on this isn't
okay and i'm worried about you and i
love you
right and we all know
we all know i know but i've never spoken
directly with him
about it my husband has a little bit but
it's all this
secret we know but haven't necessarily
acknowledged yeah so so you've heard me
say this before i think somebody needs
to turn the lights on turn the music off
of the dance and just call this what it
is right now
and that may be y'all bringing him in
over to your house and inviting him over
for dinner and just saying hey things
aren't okay and we're about to get super
involved
the best we can
we're not your parents you've got a free
ride smoking weeds awesome drinking's
awesome hooking up with girls i mean all
that's awesome but you're not okay and
we're gonna do the best we can to put a
stop to it
i love you too much
and that's going to be a relational
fracture anytime you throw up boundaries
on a 15 year old who's out of control
they're going to say i hate you you're
not my parents you don't get to do that
whatever
but it will be the first seed planted
that we love you and care about you
enough to try to keep you safe
and it may end up with him saying can i
come live with you who knows where it's
down so i'd have this conversation with
your husband what are y'all's boundaries
what's how much money were you willing
to put in on this are you willing to let
him come stay with you for a season i
mean all those things
um
if there is abuse going on if there's
all kinds if there's chaos or neglect
going on and he's going to get removed
who knows where this thing goes
but he is desperate for someone who
loves him who's an adult to step in and
say
i'm going to do it i'm at least going to
go to bed knowing i made the right phone
calls and i invited you over to my house
and said i love you and you're not safe
and you're not okay
right yeah it all seemed to be self
self-inflicted harm yeah no other signs
of external um but yeah it's very clear
there's a there's a cry for help and an
attention here
and it may shock you
how little is going on
or it may shock you how much is going on
that y'all don't know about
yeah
a lot
maybe a lot
but this 15 year old is saying somebody
please help me
and he's lucky to have you
i just don't want there to be any
illusions this is going to be one of
those like the music's going to swell
and it's going to be an after-school
special kind of moment it's going to be
really hard on your marriage it's going
to be hard on your family dynamics it's
going to screw up thanksgiving and
christmas and all that stuff and what i
would tell you is this little boy's
worth it
yeah there's definitely already been
some strains and arguments had and
and it's yeah it's just painful painful
to watch and you you know watching from
the outside is obviously different than
being the parent and that's right you
know we think we might have all the
answers but but we probably don't i mean
i don't know for sure you don't and 100
chance go into it knowing you don't have
all the answers
that's why you the the approach you take
is here's all we can see and we're about
to act
in an over-the-top way
we're going to call everybody we can
and you may cut us off you may shut us
out you may close the doors on us and
not let us talk to him that's fine we're
going to go to bed at night knowing we
did everything we could to keep this
young boy safe because y'all are not
and i'm not going to go to my little
brother's funeral
knowing that i didn't do anything that i
stayed silent when i shouldn't have
right
i'm not going to be trying to help my
brother get a job in 15 years with a
felony on his record and i should have
said something
can y'all prevent everything no this is
not by your hand but it's in your lap
somebody you love is hurting and i'm
going to stand up and say something
yeah
that makes sense easier definitely
easier said than done oh man yes so
here's the big thing
as soon as possible you and your husband
get together and game plan it
here's who's going to say what here's
what we're going to say here's how far
we'll go financially here's how far
we'll go to open our home up you may
have little kids that you don't want
around this guy or he may be incredible
around your little kids because he's so
desperate for connection that when he
gets it he's amazing
and most 15 year olds are
most 15 year olds are extraordinary and
they are desperate for people to connect
with them
and so get all that stuff planned out
otherwise you're going to end up in a
mess and you're going to end up saying
yes to something that y'all are not
ready for or can't afford or don't have
space for etc and you're going to get
way over your skis on it and then it's
going to you're going to end up
presenting everybody it's going to be
even more chaotic
have your game plan and then have the
conversations that you need to have
and i would make sure he feels like
y'all not feels like he knows he looks
you in the eye
over a meal in your house and he knows
that you love him but he knows that love
comes with accountability and safety and
know that your parents his your in-laws
we are willing to y'all have already
blown this thing up we were willing to
just call to pay the piper on this one
and um you don't want to hang out with
us great but i can't continue to let
come over here and see the blood and the
scars on my little brother's arms
without saying something and i can't
keep hearing about him getting drunk
around us at our house can't do it can't
do it anymore he can't come over here
high anymore um we have too much respect
for you guys for him and for our own
house
and i'll say it again sarah he's lucky
to have someone in his life that loves
him like you do
and love gets really messy and really
hard sometimes so thank you so much for
continuing to restore my faith in
humanity i'm really grateful for you
guys call me back any step of the way
after these emails i mean after the
conversations they're going to be hard
they're going to be messy they're going
to go sideways call me after those and
i'll continue to walk alongside you guys
as y'all work through this um thank you
so so much for reaching out
all right so as we wrap up today's show
let's see here james brought some songs
in
um
i'm kind of a huge fan of this one this
is one of my lo-fi secret favorites
[Applause]
i love tears for fears man do you
yeah
duh
i love tears for fears
when this song comes on i turn the radio
up as loud as it will go it's it might
be overplay but it's jam way overloaded
love it but since it was overplayed
three to four decades ago i think we're
good now
love love love this song it's not one of
the greatest of all time but it's it's
pretty awesome um it's called everybody
wants to rule the world and it goes like
this
listening to this song today just feels
good welcome to your life there's no
turning back even while we sleep we'll
find you acting on your best behavior
turning your back on mother nature every
body wants to rule the world it's my own
design my own remorse helped me decide
help me make most of freedom of pleasure
nothing ever lasts
and everybody wants to rule the world
this song's good man i'm gonna listen to
it right after the show
not really james has probably got some
tasks for me to do or whatever but stay
tuned on the dr john dolone show